we are going to begin this hour with
tropical storm elsa bearing down on the
west coast of florida the storm has been
lingering near tampa
causing heavy rain and flooding there
and it's expected to make landfall on
the state's northern gulf coast
within the next few hours tropical storm
elsa was
actually hurricane elsa for several
hours yesterday but it has since
weakened it's set to be the earliest
tropical storm to make landfall
in the area in 30 years maria villarreal
is in holmes
south beach tampa maria what does it
look like there
hey good morning jerica right now what
we are feeling here on anna maria
island is a whole lot of wind right now
that's because we are on the backside of
what was hurricane
elsa now tropical storm we're on what's
called the backside the dirty side of
the storm which means as the
bands start to whip around the storm
will move inland very quickly
we had rain all night here which means
there will be some flooding
in the area and on top of that there was
a lot of trees and debris on the roadway
but the main concern
is the flooding especially as the west
coast part of florida got up to
10 inches of rain a lot of people that
we spoke with said
they were preparing for this storm and
they weren't taking any chances
no matter the size overnight elsa
pounding florida's west coast
unpacking winds of up to 75 miles an
hour
and dumping up to 15 inches of rain
it's fury on full display here at
inglewood beach in the florida keys
the rain is coming at all angles you can
see by the palm trees it's blowing
everywhere it's coming at all angles
while the force of the waves coming from
the gulf of mexico
sending water crashing over sea walls
and turning roads
into rivers further inland the wind kind
of knocked me over we had a decent gust
and knocked me over businesses and city
buildings shuttered
as nearly three dozen florida counties
declared states of emergency
governor ron de santos warned people of
what could come
be prepared to be without power for a
few days and having enough food and
water for each person in their family
including for your pets earlier tuesday
elsa hammered the keys and southwest
florida
this rain is coming in sideways and
smacking me in the face
it's a lot of wind it's the earliest
fifth named storm on record
and while floridians might be used to
facing the tropical storm threat
tampa fire chief barbara tripp had this
warning
a lot of times when you let your guards
down and think it's nothing
of course now you cause more injury or
damage to
the community as well as yourself and
your families
things have started to clear up here on
the island but we are expecting a lot of
wind
and some rain throughout the morning
other states however have already
started to prepare their residents
for tropical storm conditions in georgia
they have declared a state of emergency
and south carolina
is also urging residents to prepare for
the wet weather
jamie so early in the season maria thank
you